jackson vega wants to know what do you
think of stephen greer
um never met him
i've even been places where he was also
appearing but
i basically keep to myself
all the time anyway and
and he never uh
saw me out so never had a conversation
with him
what are some of the people that you
consider to be most credible see for me
i'm a novice in this field and i don't
know who to trust who not to trust so i
approach each person with an open mind
and i assume what they're saying is true
and i just talk to them as if they're
being honest
but obviously some people are misleading
and
i don't have enough experience i'm
unclear if you can get enough experience
to be able to discern what's
misinformation
but
either way who do you consider to be the
credible people or some credible people
well i agree that not all you hear at
events or things that are made public
are on the same
type of
plane is what
we experienced
um
i i think in in some cases they're just
outright lies but in many cases these
are people who have had some sort of
very vivid experience that they truly
believe
but
probably didn't actually happen
but
i that would be so presumptuous you know
how many people passed judgment on me
without having investigated my case
happens constantly
they they're they're so poorly versed
they they jumbled on the on the details
but yet they're attacking
they made up their minds before they
even look at the facts so i never wanted
to be guilty of that to
um say who's authentic and who's not
just on base of my impression i
definitely do have those kinds of
impressions there are some people that i
believe have definitely had authentic
they're
really recounting things that happened
to them and others
perhaps not but but
i've made a policy of not pointing to
which ones are
good and which ones aren't what led you
to believe that the people who are good
are good
like what are you picking up on or is it
subtle body language is it something
that they say that's consistent with
your experience that only those in the
know
no many many things goes into that you
know it's kind of just the same way you
and i size each other up when we have a
conversation you know um
there are some people you can tell
that they are um
um
for varicators in a kind of a way they
look at reality in a way that feeds
their
self-esteem
um
these people are called narcissists
a narcissist
is a form of mental illness
but it's really quite common and quite
destructive
but um when people hear the term
narcissist they think of
uh oh well
the old greek legend or whatever it was
where the name came from
it was supposedly
um
some character in mythology who just
uh was entranced by his own image in in
the mirror and the reflection
well no narcissism has is kind of a
sickness of uh
floundering self-esteem
that can be extremely
dangerous
and
when when you say somebody's delusional
they think you're talking about somebody
who sees pink elephants in the room or
is
mindlessly jabbering
um
incoherently
but
no people uh
that are of an
mental
illness of this sort
uh can be
very good at um
making things
fit the narrative you know
they they have um
paranoid delusions that people are
plotting against them or the things
occurred
in the basis of no evidence at all but
it's they're totally convinced by it
because
uh they need to believe it for various
psychological reasons
and a
potentially very harmful
mental condition